Kylie's always extremely vague when  there's stuff going on with Tigers Kylie  Jenner still sore over her breakup from  Tyga a source tells ET the  eighteen-year-old is livid about her  ex's behavior and can earlier this month  hot off the heels of their split Tyga  hung with this lingerie model demi Rose  who our source says was texting Tyga  during his whole relationship with Kylie  when she saw pics of them she was  furious our source adds this isn't the  first time Tyga's flirting has hurt  Kylie quote this is the exact reason  they broke up he was constantly texting  girls and lying to her about it  but the 18 year old is putting on a  brave face ET can confirm she is dating  rapper partynextdoor  though our source claims it's not that  serious  quote kylie is just living her life  right now and having fun but she's still  a little sore from tyga he was her first  real love